[موسيقى]
مرحبا نبدا كواليس هذا الاسبوع مع مسرحيه
تشارلي تشابلن واللي تعد حلم لابطالها
وفريقها اصبح واقع وحقق نجاح كبير في
الرياض يناير الماضي حيث انتقلت المسرحيه
الان لمصر لتبدا عروضها مع اقبال مشابه
وكبير جدا كونها تقدم شخصيه ثريه ومؤثره
في عالم الفن وعرضت المسرحيه الويكند
الماضي على مسرح اركان مع توافذ العديد من
صناع الفن والمشاهير لمشاهده العرض اللي
اشادوا بروعته وحيث استمر التصفيق في
نهايه العرض لاكثر من 5 دقائق كاميرا
كواليس تواجدت هناك وعدت بهذه اللقاءات
لمده ساعتين وربع عن قصه حياه شارلي شابلن
مش مجرد الصعلوك اللي بيضحك لكن الانسان
والفنان صاحب الموقف السياسيه المهمه جدا
العمل دوت خد وقت طويل جدا جدا ان احنا
نقدر زي ما بيقولش نعمل مدخل
للعمل وكان بالنسبه لي ايه هو اللاين اللي
انا هبتدي اقوله جديد عن شابلن فكان
بالنسبه لي هو تاثير اكتشفنا ان هو صاحب
موقف اجتماعي واخلاقي كبير جدا احنا
الصوره عننا عندنا كانت مشوهه وغير كافيه
لشخصيه تشارل شابلن
[موسيقى]
مسرحيه اخرى راح تتنقل حول المملكه وهي
جميل وبثينه واللي انتهى عرضها مؤخرا في
جده بعد الرياض اذ يواصل مسرح كراكيلا
تقديم اسطوره عشق في العلا في التراث
العربي واللي حكايه جميل بثينه
في قالب ملهم وجاذب عبر توظيف معرفي
لملحمه تاريخيه تبتسم بالعبقريه مع ادوات
التفعيل او التفاعل مع الجمهور وهي تحديث
في طريقه التعامل مع الحكايه وتضيف
للتقنيات للدخول لمعايشه القصه محققه
الفرصه لعدد من الموهوب السعوديين اللي
يشارك في انجاز هذا العمل الفني المسرحي
اكثر من 300 مبدع من المعدين والكتاب او
الشعراء يمثل السعوديين نسبه 40% منهم
مسرحيه جميل وبتكلم عن قصه جميله اللي عاش
في مدينه العلا وحب لبثينه حيث انه حب
فضحوا بين القبيلتين فتسبب الى طرده من
هذه القبيله وانتقل الى بلاط الشعراء بلا
ضمير المؤمنين وعاش وقابل الشعراء في
هالبلاط وعاش معاهم وتتكلم
القصه بطريقه
استعراضيه غنائيه يعني فرجه
للجمهور بشكل جمالي اكثر الجميل بالقصه
تاريخ هذه المنطقه الشخصيات شخصيات عاشوا
بهذه المنطقه بمنطقه العلا
[موسيقى]
صعب جدا يعني
اكيد هو كان طويل طبعا متعب يعني 60 حلقه
ايوه امنيتك اهي سرقه وتحس ما بدك ابره
طويله احس ان المسلسل ناقصه حاجه لو
الاستاذ دلال مش فيه
هذه السنه هو مسلسل الكبير قوي الجزء
السابع العام الماضي طبعا بتفاعل هو
متابعه كبيره ابرز الاوجه الجديده اللي
انضمت لعائله الكبير كان مصطفى غريب واللي
لعب دور ولد احمد مكي اللي شرب حليب مضاف
له ماده تفاعليه عشان يتحول من طفل اللي
رجل التقينا بالفنان مصطفى غريب وسالناه
هل رح يرجع معهم الطفل مره اخرى عم يستكمل
هو دوره كالابنه الرجل الكبير قوي وماذا
كمان عن بقيه العمل كلنا موجودين كلنا
موجودين احنا بنجيب بنزود ضيوف شرف بس كل
الكاس موجود بس
في كل الاجزاء بقى ده شرف ليا وشرف لاي حد
يشارك في الكبير
هذا الاسبوع بلقطات الحفل المفاجاه الاشهر
لان جمباكستان والهند واللي اقاموا حفل
للجاليه الباكستانيه والهنديه في جده
ابرزهم النجم كومار سانو واللي حبيت
بتفاعل لافت جدا